Let's go to a caller from the four one three
area code.
A very special area code.
Back in the original stomping grounds of the
David Pakman show in western Massachusetts
for one three.
Who's this?
Where are you calling from?
Hello, David.
I am a new viewer.
I've been watching probably for about six
months now.
OK, Jordan.
Jordan.
And where are you calling from?
I'm calling from western Massachusetts.
You told a little town called Ludlow.
Ludlow, incredible.
And Field Ludlow, known for what is less well
known for large Portuguese population.
Yes.
And our fantastic high school soccer team.
And the soccer team.
That's exactly right.
All right.
What's going on today?
Enda's.
But if you can try to keep the phone just
a little further from your mouth just so you
don't come in so hot.
Yeah.
You got it.
Beautiful.
So my question is, what do you think the tipping
point was or the sudden change in rhetoric
from Trump regarding Corona virus was the
new campaign manager.
It obviously wasn't the Tulsa rally.
Now a backlash for the fire to Pouchy each
week.
What do you think the tipping point was?
I think it's desperation.
I think at this point.
So it's possible that removing Brad Parr scale
as the manager and bringing on that guy, Bill
Stepien, I think his name is.
It's possible that Stepien said, listen, I
will do it, but you've got to listen to me.
And what you're referring to for people who
didn't see it as earlier this week when Trump
restarted the Corona virus, press briefings,
he did the first one on Tuesday.
He came out and talked about how in favor
he is of masks.
Trump said it may get worse before it gets
better rather than constantly telling us that
it's about to go away.
A very notable change in rhetoric.
I think it's desperation.
I think at this point, Trump sees the polling.
He publicly says it's fake polling.
I think he knows that it's real polling.
And this is his last shot.
He's realizing people start voting in six
weeks.
The Corona virus is going to be here for some
time.
The vaccine is not going to be widely available
before the election.
And he needs to try something else.
What he's done so far hasn't worked.
I think he's a desperate, cornered, scared
man.
The paramilitaries in Portland are part of
it.
Try to create some confrontations to make
protesters look bad.
Maybe that'll help a new rhetoric.
It's desperation and I don't know whose idea
it was, but clearly someone got to him and
said, you've got to take a new approach.
I would like to think that in a more sane
world, that the scientific backlash and especially
from the CDC ouchy and Redfield.
Yeah.
Are actually picking up for Foushee and that
maybe, just maybe he would have listened to
that.
But obviously, it has everything to do with
the reelection.
And everything that's happening right now
is about reelection.
And Trump's gambit was reopen, reopen schools,
reopen businesses, reopen everything.
Hope that it doesn't get bad right away so
that things are OK enough in October that
people vote to reelect Trump.
Clearly, it's not happening.
And the numbers have gone the opposite direction.
So he's trying the next thing and it is all
about getting reelected.
We'll see if it works.
Yeah, I guess like the the last example I
would offer up is do you think that there
is some internal charts or I'm sorry, I'm
getting like the internal polling scientific
word.
No, not polling, but charts that are showing
the projected death rate that is to come in
August, October, September and November.
Oh, certainly.
And I mean, listen, some of those are public
and they're talking about I think it's in
the range of, you know, reaching anywhere
from two to two hundred and ten to two hundred
and sixty thousand deaths.
If things continue to accelerate and I'm sure
that the White House has all that data.
Yeah, yeah.
Well, thank you for your time, David.
All right.
Appreciate the phone call.
Thank you very much.
Great to hear from you